[MUSIC]
Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this episode
of Dartisans.
My name is Seth Ladd.
I'm a Dart developer advocate
with the Chrome team.
And today we're going
to try something a
little new on the show.
Today, I want to run
through a bunch of
demos with Dart Editor.
We featured the Dart Editor
back in one of our first
Dartisans, almost a year ago.
And a lot has changed
since then.
So, if you haven't seen Dart
Editor in a while or you saw
it almost a year ago, today
is the show for you.
We're going to run through how
to download, how to load up
files, and all the great
features of Dart Editor, that
helps you scale from small
scripts, all the way to a
large apps with, say, hundreds
of thousands of lines of code,
and maybe a hundred or
developers on your team.
And so with that, let's jump
to the screen and go to a
bunch of demos.
First thing to note is, that
it's very easy to get started
with Dart Editor.
The nice thing about this editor
is there's really no
installation process.
And so you can just download
the zip file, unzip it, and
you're off and running.
To grab the zip file, go
over to dartland.org.
You'll see up at the top a list
of tools and, of course,
jump to the editor.
Now we're auto selecting which
editor for you, based on your
operating system.
And the editor does work on
Linux, Mac, and Windows.
And so, here I'm on a Mac.
Now, I'm not actually going
to download it today.
But you can see right here at
the top is a blue button for
download Dart Editor.
Again it's a standalone install,
very, very simple.
So it's very easy
to get started.
So we're going to use the
magic of television.
And voila, our editor
is now installed.
So it's important to note,
there's a couple different
versions of the editor that
we have out there.
We have weekly versions
and nightly versions.
Now, I recommend running the
weeklies or what they call the
integration builds.
These come out about every week
and they're tested by the
editor team.
And that's, I believe, the
best place for you.
If you like living on
the edge, we do
have nightly builds.
Those are kicked off by
build bots we have.
There's not a lot of testing
there, but if there's some
particular bug that you
critically need fixed, and it
might have gotten in
the previous day,
you can try the nightlies.
But I recommend the weekly
or integration builds.
The auditor does have auto
update features now, which is
really nice.
You can optionally opt-in
to auto updates.
And it will download in the
background, and then give you
a nice little hints that it's
time to restart your editor.
And so, for the past month or
two I've just been running on
auto update, and just living on
whatever the latest weekly
is, which is nice.
So let's go and actually see
Dart Editor in action.
So once you've got it installed,
which again is just
unzipping a zip file,
you're presented
with a welcome screen.
And this is really nice
because it helps you
just ease into Dart.
I want to show a couple
of features
here the welcome screen.
Right here you can create
applications or
open existing code.
We also have helpful links
around the documentation, or
tutorials, or the O'Reilly book
that we just published.
And my favorite are the sample
applications down here.
And we'll get to these in a
minute, but you can see that
we have a bunch of different
samples.
Showing off different bits
and parts of either
HTML5 and or Dart code.
And they just load up into your
editor, and so you can
start playing with them.
And it's non-destructive and so
we really want you to try
these samples, play with
the code, and see
which you can do.
So let's go ahead and
jump in here.
On the left, we have
the files view.
The files view is a way to
think about your Dart
applications as directories.
Dart applications are really
scripts that link to other
scripts and other libraries.
And so, you don't have this
heavyweight concept of a
project in Dart Editor.
You just have the directory that
you happen to open, which
contains any number of files,
like dart files, HTML files,
CSS files, et cetera.
So it's very lightweight,
lightweight way to interact
with your projects.
I typically think of one
project per directory.
Let's load up.
Let's go ahead and get
rid of this here.
Let's load up one of the easiest
samples to check out,
which is the clock sample.
So by clicking on clock from
the welcome screen, you can
see that it creates a copy of
that code on my files view,
and then immediately opens the
files in the editor itself.
So, just quickly now, you
probably want to run it.
Well, when you open up the
clock folder here, in the
files view, you'll see that
we have CSS files HTML
files and CSS files.
So let's run the actual
application.
You can run it by right-clicking
on the main
Dart file, and choosing run in
Dartium or run as JavaScript.
Now the quickest way to run
your applications in the
editor is run as Dartium.
Dartium is a build of Chromium
with the Dart virtual machine
embedded inside.
So just like normal web
programming, we can just edit
a few files and hit reload,
where reload is
acting as your compiler.
We can get that same very fast
iterative development cycle
with Dartium and the
virtual machine.
That means there's no
compilation step.
So let's go ahead and
run in Dartium.
And here it's downloading a file
from Google code which is
a bootstrap file
and here we go.
So this is actual Dart code
running in a Dart virtual
machine, inside a custom
build of Chromium.
So this is a pretty cool demo.
And this quick added reload
cycle is very, very nice when
you're doing development.
But when you want to deploy to
the open web, of course, you
need to compile to JavaScript.
So let's see how that happens.
So we're going back to
your editor now.
And if you right-click on the
Dart file, you can choose the
other option, run
as JavaScript.
Now this will run the
Dart to JS compiler,
itself written in Dart.
Converting the Dart code
into JavaScript code.
And then launching into your
particular stable browser.
Right here I'm running Chrome.
As we wait for this
file to load.
Here we go, so same exact app,
but it's compiled to
JavaScript.
And this is running just
right in Chrome.
So to prove that, we can open
up the dev tools, and go to
sources, and sure enough
here's the
JavaScript file itself.
So pretty cool.
So, generally, we recommended
doing the editing in, and
testing in Dartium.
And then when you're ready to
deploy, compile the JavaScript
for your modern browsers like
Firefox, IE9 and above,
Chrome, Opera, and, of course,
Mobile Safari,
and Chrome for Android.
Now is very, very easy to
run your application by
right-clicking on the file.
But we also have a run manager,
so in the editor you
can see this green run button,
up in the top toolbar.
If you drop this down you can
see all the different run
configurations that you have,
that link to all the files in
your files view on the left.
And you could also
manage them, too.
And so this is a nice way, say,
if you want to create a
custom-run configuration.
Maybe you want to turn
off debugging.
Maybe you want to send some
custom flags to Dartium or
Chrome, when you
start them up.
You can use the manage run
configurations option.
But most the time you'll be
just using the simple
right-click run as Dartium and
right-click run as JavaScript.
I find that I use those
almost every time.
OK, so let's look at
some of the editing
features of Dart Editor.
Again, we'll stick with the
clock sample here, just to
keep things simple.
Now, Dart is a structured
but dynamic language.
And so that helps you scale,
again, for very small sets of
scripts, maybe you don't even
use a class, all the way up to
hundreds of thousands
of lines of code.
And on that journey as you
scale, you're going to be
encountering more lines of code,
more libraries, and more
developers.
And to compensate for the added
complexity, it's nice to
have tools that help you
navigate and work your way
through the code.
So let's show some of the
features of Dart Editor that
helps us scale up in terms of
lines of code and number of
developers.
Probably the one that most
people are used to is the code
completion.
Now as projects grow, you can't
keep all the libraries,
and features, and
functionalities in your head
at all times.
And so it's nice to have an
editor to give you that
assistance as you go.
And so code completion
can help you do that.
So by typing a variable name
and hitting dot, the editor
will say, OK, well, I know what
type this variable is,
and in most cases it does, and
he'll give you then all the
methods you can call
on that variable.
And so for here, on the window
object, which just comes from
HTML5, you can see all the
different options now.
This is really nice.
So again, if you are not
entirely familiar with an API
and you want to explore,
code completion can
really, really help you.
I see for here, it just it
reduces the options as you go,
and very, very helpful.
OK, so I really like
code completion.
Another really nice feature
is the outline.
Again, it's about helping you
not have to keep the entire
program structure
in your head.
Your tools should be able
to help you with this.
And so, one way is to
conceptualize, what is the
outline of the files that
I'm looking at.
So, if you go up Tools and you
show the outline view.
And here, I'll just
drag this up here.
You can see here, it's
an outline of the
file that I have open.
And so it shows you the class,
it shows you the static
members of that class,
it shows you the
fields and the methods.
And so this is a nice way,
especially if you're working
with very large files, to be
able to navigate those files
very quickly, if you know the
name of one of the methods.
Or if you're just curious,
and what's the
structure of this file.
Of course, if you click one of
the items in the outline on
the left, it will jump
you directly to that
location on the right.
So again, just trying to help
you navigate that code easily.
Speaking about navigation, a
common question when you're
dealing with large amounts of
code, or even just acclimating
to new projects is, who's using
this code or does this
code call out, or who
calls this code?
Well, the editor can help
you with that as well.
So here, let's just use
this tick method here.
My question here is, does
anyone call tick, what
is this used for?
So you can right-click on this,
and a bunch of options
show up, find references,
find caller.
So I'm interested does anyone
call this method.
So by choosing find callers
and scrolling down to the
bottom, you can see
the callers view.
And sure enough, there seems
to be two places that uses
this tick method, both
in this class.
And I can just click on these
and it takes me right to them.
So this is again really helpful
for navigating your
code, but it also really helpful
when you want to know,
is this code safe
for deletion?
Certainly, the best thing as
developers we can do, is
delete code.
That's always more fun
than writing code.
And it's imperative to know, is
this code safe to delete?
So, I use the find callers to
help me understand, is this
dead code out there?
Let's look at a couple other
navigation features in the
Dart Editor, as well.
Well, let's look at the
opposite direction.
So let's say I'm looking here
at window.requestAn
imationFrame(tick) and
I'm wondering, what
is this tick thing?
Is it a variable, is it a
method, who declares or even
defines it?
Well, you can go the
opposite way.
From find callers as you
can open declaration.
And that will jump you to where
that variable or method
is defined.
And, of course, it's
right here in tick.
So really, really helpful for
navigating your code.
Now, of course, this is just
a simple demo application.
Does this really work when you
have, say, hundreds of
thousands of lines of code?
Well, to show that, let's jump
to one of our more complex
Dart projects, which is the
Dart to JS compiler.
This itself is written in Dart
and it converts Dart code into
modern JavaScript, to run
on all modern browsers.
And this is a lot of code and
I'm not exactly familiar with
this project at all.
But I want to show you how,
say, you can load up, and
easily and quickly navigate
something that you've never
seen before.
So I'm just going to pick a
random file here from this is
the Dart to JS project here,
this is the compiler.
Again, I've never seen this
code here before.
But one of the things I'm kind
of curious about is, this tree
element, so, what is that?
So I can right-click on that,
open declaration.
And boom.
In a whole other file, it makes
the hundreds of files,
the hundreds of thousands lines
of code, the Dart editor
immediately pops open the
definition of tree element.
So that's really useful.
I might say, OK, this is
kind of interesting.
Get selector, I wonder
who calls this?
So again, I can find callers.
And sure enough there's a lot
of code that calls that.
And I can double-click from the
callers view, and it jumps
me right to the usage
of that method.
Now again, this is scanning
hundreds of thousands of lines
of code, hundreds of files.
And it's almost instantaneous.
So really, really nice for
acclimating to new projects.
OK, so there's more features
there for navigation, but
hopefully that gives you a
sense of how you can jump
around your projects
with Dart Editor.
Now, I want to talk about some
of the feedback that Dart
Editor can provide.
Dart is a dynamic language,
but it's also structured.
And that means that the analysis
engine of the editor
can give you early warnings,
and early feedback based on
the code that you've written,
to help you track down,
identify, and fix errors before
you run the code.
And, this is again, it's so
important when you have to
deal with huge amounts of code,
that maybe the unit
tests take minutes and minutes
to run, or you just want to
work in one little file here,
and just play around the
changes here.
You really, really appreciate
that instant feedback that
these editor tools
can give you.
So let's go back to the
clock demo here.
And try to trigger
some warnings.
The things that we're going to
be interested in here is, the
problems view, which is
typically down at the bottom
of your editor.
Now this is going to list all
the warnings and errors across
all the different projects.
And you can see here that
there's a lot of different
problems going on, in projects
that I'm not
that interested in.
So I'm going to right-click
on my files view, on the
individual folders here
and I'm going to
choose, don't analyze.
Now that's going to tell the
editor, hey don't worry about
analyzing or peering too deeply
into the files in here.
I'm not that interested
in this right now.
Other editors might have
this functionality like
a close or a hide.
And as you can see, as I tell
the editor, don't analyze this
stuff, my problems
view is getting
reduced, which is good.
Because I want to just focus on
one particular project here
to show you.
So, I'm just about turning off
all the, there you go.
So I have an empty problems
view, which is good because
now I'm going to introduce
some problems for us.
Now, there's two kinds of
feedback here that the editor
can tell you.
One is warnings, and
one is errors.
And it's important to understand
the distinction
between these two.
Warnings in Dart are, hey, you
might have some issue, but it
may actually run.
I don't have enough information
to tell you.
So I'm going to let the program
compile and run.
Dart has a philosophy of
innocent until proven guilty.
That is, we know that the
ceremonial type checkers, if
you will, don't always catch
all potential problems, and
especially every time you do
a cast in a traditional
statically typed languages,
you're trying to express
something that that type checker
is unable to express.
And you're kind of busting out
of the rigid rules system.
Well, if you're allowed to bust
out of the rigid rule
system, shouldn't a language
come along that gives you more
flexibility, and trusts
you a little bit more?
That's Dart's philosophy.
And so it's going to give you
warnings, but it's going to
let you run the program.
Contrast that with errors.
Errors are show stopping
problems, that the Dart
program knows will prevent your
program from running.
So if you see the red for
errors, that means program
can't run, you should
fix this right now.
If you see the yellow warnings,
that means program
may run, but you probably
want to check this out.
So let's see if we can trigger
both kinds of problems here.
OK, so I'm back over
to Dart Editor.
And let's just play around with
some of the types here.
Let's just change one of
these ints to a string.
So, clearly, I'm setting display
hour to zero, which is
an integer, but I'm annotating
the displayed hour
variable as a string.
Of course, these things
don't quite match.
So down here, you can see
immediate feedback and two
warnings that int is not
assignable to string.
I also get a warning right,
when the variable is
initialized here, and you can
hover over that and see that.
I also, of course, get a warning
here in the gutter.
Now, I can just simply click
on these problems to get
jumped right to their
locations.
So that's really nice.
Again, the editor helping
me navigate my code.
But this is a warning.
Now, why is it a warning
that strings
can be set to integers?
Well, remember that Dart
is a dynamic language.
And these type annotations,
the string and int for
instance, don't affect the
runtime semantics of the code.
So at run time, it's as if
I simply used var here.
But, of course, I love the
instant feedback and so I use
these type annotations, which
are perfect for development.
So I'm going to put
this back in.
But you can see that, so you can
see that changing the type
annotation will, in fact,
trigger a warning.
Let's go back here and see if
we can trigger an error.
OK, import dart foo.
Now here's an example
of an error.
Let's say I'm importing a
library that, just flat out,
doesn't exist.
Now Dart Editor knows
that there's no such
library called dart foo.
And here you can see the red
underline, you can see the red
error over here, and, of course,
in the problems view
you can see an error here.
This is really, really cool.
Again, instant feedback.
And the editor's telling me
before I even run the program,
hey, something's wrong.
You should probably fix this.
So I really, really appreciate
that instant feedback.
So that's a little bit about
warnings and errors.
OK, so we looked at running
apps, and I want to dive into
running apps a little bit more,
and show the run config.
So let's go to, let's go here.
Let's go manage launches, and
we're going to manage the
launch for this clock.
We're not, maybe this is going
to be a little bit too
complicated.
Here we go.
OK, good.
So there's going to be two kinds
of launches for clock.
One is with Dartium, which is
with the Dart virtual machine.
One is with JavaScript, that
is for modern web browsers
deployed out there
in the wild.
Now, one of the main things that
I recommend you play with
is the run in checked mode
configuration option, in
manage launches.
Run in checked mode defines
what happens when the Dart
virtual machine, or the Dart
run times encounters type
annotations that don't
quite make sense.
In checked mode if, say,
we set string to a
zero, it will fail.
And if you uncheck checked mode,
then that will work OK.
So it's a nice way to say
develop in checked mode, and
catch some of those early
warnings when you have type
notations that don't
quite match.
But when you want to test, say,
pure speed, or if you
want to test the behavior as if
you were to deploy your app
into the wild, where checked
mode not run by default.
You can turn off checked
mode here.
You can also see options here
about enabling debugging, and
turning on experimental
WebKit features.
So if you want to
play with how to
run, use manage launches.
Let's go ahead and play with
some of the debugging here, as
a good transition to
some of the other
features the editor provides.
Now let's close this and let's
go back to clock here.
So one of the best things about
the debugger is being
able to set break points.
So let's take a break
point right here
inside the tick method.
And if we run this again, of
course, setting this break
point here requires a virtual
machine, because the editor
hooks up the debugging session
directly to the VM that's
embedded inside Chromium
for you.
And sure enough, the
program stops right
at the break point.
And you could go over here
on my right and see
the debugger in action.
So standard debugging
features here.
Useful and familiar to people
who like their Eclipses and
IntelliJs and Visual Studios,
we have this in Dart editor.
You can browse variables, you
can walk the stack, you can
even jump over and jump into
methods and functions.
All this functionality
is available.
And you can see here that this
is a live debugging session,
with what's inside Dartium.
So here the program is paused,
of course, because we're in a
debugging session, if
I hit run here.
Or I turn off the break point,
and then hit run.
Of course, the programs
running again.
So this is really, really good
to help you track down bugs,
or you want to know the state
of your variables.
You could do this live without
ever leaving your editor, and
while you're controlling the
running program in Dartium.
Which I think is really,
really cool.
OK, so as the program grows in
lines of code and complexity,
you want to maintain it.
And to maintain it you often
have to move code around, or
you have to clean up old code,
or you have to, say, rename
variable names that don't really
make sense anymore.
And to do that the technique is
called refactoring, which
changes the structure
of the code without
changing the behavior.
And this is a common technique
as you evolve over time.
Now the Dart editor has some
refactorings built in.
One of my favorite is the
rename refactoring.
Let's do this now.
Let's say, for instance, that
this time variable name here
is maybe not as clear
as it could be.
And so I want to rename this.
Now, you could do a global
search and replace, of course.
But that can catch usages of
the word time that aren't
direct related to this
particular rename.
Now, because Dart is a
structured language, the
editor can statically analyze
the code structure and help
you refactor cleanly
and safely.
So let's right click on this
variable name time.
And let's see here, rename,
and time stamp, and I can
change the name of this, in
real time, Dart editor is
renaming my variables for me
on the fly, safely, for me.
So this is the kind of things
that I want my editor to do.
Like, I don't want to have to
use grep to do refactoring.
And I don't want to have to do
complicated searches across
all my code, to find out
who uses the code.
The editor is doing this stuff
for me, so I can actually
focus on solving real business
problems, not managing complex
code bases.
So I really, really
appreciate that.
The editor has other the
refactoring features, like
in-lining of functions
or others.
And so experiment, play around
and see how it can help you
manage your code.
One other feature of the editor
is its integration into
the Dart ecosystem.
So we've been playing a lot
with the code here, but we
have some other things like
package manager, which allows
you to discover, install,
and manage third party
dependencies.
Most ecosystems have this.
Ruby has Gems, Python has Eggs,
Java has Maven, Dart has
Pub, the package manager.
And the editor has Pub
integration or package
management, built right
in for you.
And so I want to show
a demo of that.
Let's go back to one of
my favorite apps here,
catpic-app, and we're going to
turn the analyzer back on, so
you can see the errors that
we have in the system.
So here is the sample
application that I have.
Now, it uses three different
packages and I haven't run the
package install process yet,
because I want to show you
what happens beforehand.
So, of course, I've
got these errors.
Now, how do I get these packages
into my system?
Well, I use a pubspec.yaml
file, which declares the
dependencies and where to
find those dependencies.
So here I've got two
dependencies, each pointing to
a GitHub repo.
We also have a package hosting
service at pub.dartlang.org,
where you find many third party
dependencies, or third
party packages for you to
us in your own app.
Now if we select the files
directory here, and go to
Tools and run Pub install,
that's going to parse the
pubspec.yaml file, that
I have for this
particular project here.
It's going to pull down,
download, symlink, set
everything else up for you.
And then you can see here,
this is a little bug.
But if we open up again, then
the errors are gone.
And so, it's nice.
You get a really nice, smooth
integration with Pub, our
package manager.
Of course, if we run this now,
you can see here boom,
catpics, one of the
best apps I have.
So enjoy that.
But, of course, what's important
here is that, I only
wrote about seven lines
of code to make
this application work.
I used the third party packages
for the catpics
themselves, the simple widgets
here, the simple frame here.
And each one of those
was pulled
from different packages.
And because Dart is a structured
language with
first-class formal support for
things like libraries, and
classes, you can actually have
independent, third-party
authors all work together.
And you, as an application
developer, can integrate these
things, and have good certainty
that they're all
going to play nicely.
So I really like the Pub
integration in the editor.
So I should point out some of
the customizations you can do
in the editor.
If you open up the preferences,
as I've done
here, you can see that you can
show line numbers, you can
print the margins, enable
code folding, excuse me.
You can also manipulate the
fonts here, and dictate the
behavior of errors
and warnings.
The point with this is, in the
preferences, you have some
nice control over the look
and feel of the editor.
And the behavior of some of the
editor features for you.
You can also control the auto
updates functionality as well.
And so when you get the editor
everything's set to go, but
know that you can tweak some
of these features, as well,
which I like.
OK, so that's a whirlwind tour
of some of the features and
functionality of the editor.
We saw how easy it is
to get started.
You just open a zip file.
Browsing around code and
navigating code, especially
code that's unfamiliar to you,
is really easy with the
outlines, and the jump to
definitions, and jump to
callers functionality.
We saw debugging, setting break
points, and stepping
through code.
We saw launching apps, both into
Dartium, our version of
Chromium with the Dart virtual
machine, and compiling to
JavaScript.
We saw some of the customization
features and the
integration with some
of the larger
ecosystem of the Dart project.
So hopefully this gives
you a taste of what
the editor can do.
We should note that while this
looks like Eclipse, this is a
completely built from
the ground up
version of the editor.
And so it's lightweight and
streamlined, but if you like
Eclipse we have the equivalent
functionality here, as an
Eclipse plug-in.
And the good folks at JetBrains
also have a Dart
plug-in for their IntelliJ
and WebStorm editor.
And if rich editors aren't
your bag, we also have
plug-ins for Vim, Sublime,
TextMate, and Emacs.
And so hopefully you can find
an editing experience that
works well with you.
No matter what you choose,
we hope that you try
and write Dart code.
Have fun with it, and really
broaden scale from small
scripts, that use just
functions, too large apps that
really deliver on the user
expectations for modern,
really cool HTML5 features.
With that, we'd love to have
a call for feedback.
We have a Dart mailing list, and
Stack Overflow, and one of
my favorite things the other is
the send feedback button.
Do not be shy.
Use this, tell us what's working
for you, what features
do you need, what seems
to be a bug?
This goes straight to the editor
team and we take this
stuff really seriously, and
really appreciate any feedback
that you have.
So with that, I think we're
going to wrap up today's
episode of Dartisans.
And again thank you very
much for joining us.
And see this next time in a
couple weeks, where we're
going to talk in depth about
Dart and web components.
And we're going to meet the
godfather of web components,
and some of the engineers
working on Dart web
components.
And give you a deep dive in
Dart and web components.
So, thanks very much,
and we'll see you
next time on Dartisans.